[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu den richtigen
fragen hierbei bild die russischen
atomraketen so sehen sie aus
normalerweise zeigt russlands präsident
putin sie zum militär paraden groß her
ansonsten lagern die aber in russland in
irgendwelchen bunkern rum das hat sich
heute geändert heute hat russlands
präsident putin dieser atomraketen in
alarmbereitschaft versetzt hier werden
wir diskutieren was bedeutet das für die
welt was bedeutet das für uns alle das
diskutieren wir gleich mit den
klitschko-brüdern die uns zugeschaltet
sind selbst in alarmbereitschaft aktuell
in kiew sie sind uns gleich beide
gemeinsam witali und wladimir
zugeschaltet und wir diskutieren darüber
hier im studium mit dem neuen künftigen
csu general stefan maier hier zu gast
bei bild und michael müller berlins
regierender bürgermeister bis vor kurzem
jetzt im bundestag für die spd und
zugeschaltet und ich freue mich ganz
besonders über wladimir kaminer heute
den schriftsteller der mit uns
diskutiert und auch ralf thiele
diskutiert mit uns der lange bei der
nato war und uns die militärischen blick
hier in der sendung schildern wird und
analysieren wird aber zunächst hier im
studio stephan mayer wir bekommen diese
meldung hier auf den tisch wir sind
sowieso schon schockiert angesichts der
ereignisse der vergangenen tage und
jetzt heißt es die atomwaffen hat
russlands präsident in alarmbereitschaft
versetzt was macht diese meldung mit
ihnen und was bedeutet sie für uns ja
persönlich geht es mir so man meint es
könne gar nicht mehr schlimmer werden
wie sie richtig sorgen mann ist ohnehin
schon schockiert und und vollkommen
paralysiert im hinblick auf die diese
schrecklichen bilder die uns ja
stündlich aus der ukraine erreichen und
jetzt diese meldung die ist natürlich
schon noch mal eine verschärfung der
situation man muss jetzt trotzdem kühlen
kopf bewahren die nato die 30 mit 330
nato mitgliedsländer müssten mit
sicherheit jetzt auch sich eng abstimmen
konzertieren auch nicht überreagieren um
das auch klar zu sagen ich glaube bei
allem sollte man nach wie vor der ratio
auch den vorrang geben aber natürlich
ist diese jüngste entwicklung der
letzten stunden noch einmal in
besonderer weise alarmiert also was
bedeutet das jetzt kühlen kopf bewahren
noch einmal nachgefragt bei ihnen herr
meier bedeutet das jetzt nicht dass die
nato das selber auch tun sollte ich
glaube man muss wirklich aufpassen dass
man jetzt nicht zu einer noch weiteren
eskalation der ohnehin ja schon sehr
zugespitzte situation leider verliert
auch er versetzt doch seine waffen in
alarmbereitschaft jetzt müssen wir bei
der nato wieder sagen wir müssen
rücksicht nehmen eigentlich sagt man
muss fix wieder aufzunehmen ganz im
gegenteil
berücksichtigt brauchte der kerl
beileibe nicht mehr braucht eine klare
antwort und so schlimm die situation ist
und so unfassbar ist ja nach wie vor ist
dass es diesen aggressiven diesen
brutalen und verwerflichen angriffskrieg
von putin und es ist putins krieg auf
die ukraine gibt so erfreulich ist es
dann doch auf der anderen seite dass die
westliche staatengemeinschaft
zusammensteht aber war es eine klare
antwort von ihnen jetzt was wäre die
klare antwort von der deutschen politik
von der nato eben die eigenen atomwaffen
nicht in alarmbereitschaft zu versetzen
ist das eine klare antwort ich möchte
jetzt beileibe nicht so weit gehen jetzt
hier sofort die alarmbereitschaft für
atomwaffen der usa oder andere
atommächte zu proklamieren ich glaube
man muss eben wie gesagt wirklich kühlen
kopf bewahren wir haben in den letzten
tagen so schlimm sich die situation
zugespitzt hat sehr konsistent und sehr
kohärent reagiert mit unterschiedlichen
aktionen mit verschiedensten stufen auch
an sanktionen und die
kehrtwende der bundesregierung die wir
als cdu csu ausdrücklich befürworten
insbesondere wir als csu als partei der
bundeswehr befürworten es dass die ampel
regierung sich jetzt obwohl sie zunächst
den verteidigungsetat reduzieren wollte
sich für eine steigerung des
verteidigers finanzierten bundeswehr
muss man auch da sagen michael müller
bei uns im studio wir haben über diese
schauerliche nachricht heute aus
russland gesprochen haben die gehört
hier wie dicht sind wir nach ihrer
einschätzung an einem einsatz von
atomwaffen ich hoffe wir sind weit
entfernt davon es ist natürlich eine
weitere eskalation in diesem
militärischen wahnsinn den wir da jetzt
alle seit tagen erleben und was mich
besonders bedrückt ist dass ich nicht
mehr sicher bin
wie und von wem putin eigentlich beraten
wird und ob er sich bewusst ist was er
da tut wie er mit dem feuer spielt auch
seinem eigenen volk er gegenüber ich
teile aber die einschätzung dass es
jetzt auch an uns ist weiterhin mit
kühlem kopf aller klarheit zu reagieren
durch sanktionen auch durch militärische
verstärkung und einsatz das ist ja jetzt
auch heute vom bundeskanzler angekündigt
worden auch unterstützung für die
ukraine aber wir müssen diese spirale
die wir aus den 80er jahren kennen mit
atomwaffen zu bedrohen die müssen wir
durchbrechen da dürfen wir nicht noch
eins drauf dass er ja nicht geschafft
jetzt geht er ja genau diesen schritt
die frage ist wie wir das schaffen diese
spirale zu durchbrechen indem wir weiter
schockiert und offenbar völlig
unvorbereitet auf die schritte schauen
die putin gehe es ist ja nicht so dass
wir jetzt unvorbereitet sind ich sage ja
na ja es haben sich ja dinge verändert
es haben sich dinge verändert auch in
der bereitschaft militärisch zu
unterstützen durch die sanktionen aber
auch heute im bundestag es von allen
fraktionen bestätigt worden wir werden
auch weiter im gespräch bleiben und wir
müssen es deutlich machen gerade als
internationale solidargemeinschaft gegen
putins diese müssen wir deutlich machen
ist danach passiert herr scholz hat im
monat gesprochen eine tatsächlich
eindrucksvolle regierungserklärung sehr
klar das hätte man sich an höher
gewünscht es kam aber jetzt es wurde
über waffenlieferungen gesprochen es
wurde eine massive auf erhöhung der
beteiligung starts er war immer ein
sondervermögen 100 milliarden obendrauf
gesprochen dass wurde angekündigt nur
danach kam die ankündigung von vladimir
putin jetzt werden die atome kredit in
den alarm bereits und wir müssen auch
jetzt weiter deutlich machen in so einer
auseinandersetzung die er mit der er
droht gibt es keine gewinner das muss
man immer wieder auch im dialog deutlich
machen da gibt es keine gewinner auch er
wird kein gewinner sein und deswegen ist
es richtig dass deutlich zu machen in
aller entschiedenheit als internationale
solidargemeinschaft aber nicht sofort
auch wieder mit atomwaffen zu bedrohen
herr thiele oberst a d sie müssen uns
das so hoffen wir einmal militärisch
einschätzen was bedeutet dass sie
überhaupt erhöhte alarmbereitschaft für
atomwaffen was passiert da technisch auf
der russischen seite jetzt
wurde seine streitkräfte dir
entsprechend real streitkräfte
alarmieren da hingegen dass sie jetzt
einsatzbereit sind nicht im urlaub etwas
machen wobei das sehr wahrscheinlich
ohnehin abwegig dass ich jetzt im urlaub
sind nicht also trotz machte sie
aufmerksam auf das
auf möglichen
einsatz erfordern ist dafür sehen nicht
dass er trotz meine interpretation ist
doch weniger bedrohlich er zeigt uns die
martha instrumente das ist das was ja de
facto macht mit der aufforderung und
sich aus dem konflikt herauszuhalten und
das und von daher sagte ich habe das
ganze eskalation spor folio zur hand ich
kann eskalieren eskalation dominanz ist
dafür das stichwort und ich fürchte er
hat recht in welcher kürze oder in
welcher zeit wären denn dann die
atomraketen einsatzbereit kann man das
sagen welche also manche sind praktisch
anderen üblichen einsatzbereitschaft was
er tatsächlich besonders erschreckend zu
den westen ist er hat er mittlerweile
mehrere modelle seiner überschall waffen
einsatzbereit das sind waffen für die
der westen noch keine antwort hat also
wir wissen nicht wie wir so etwas auch
werden sollten wir kommen innerhalb
weniger minuten an ihre ziele die usa
planen in den nächsten vier jahren die
ersten einsatzbereit zu bekommen also
wir sehen der rest ist insgesamt etwas
blank was in diesem thema ansteht und
ich denke mal wir sind gut beraten hier
tatsächlich nicht mit zu eskalieren
sondern den kühlen kopf zu bewahren und
darüber hinaus uns dann mal gedanken zu
machen wie wir unsere eigene
wehrhaftigkeit verbessern können jetzt
läuft genau das bei der nato ab
vielleicht können sie das schildern als
ein mann der eben lange bei der nato war
jetzt kommt diese meldung da rein man
erfährt dass das russlands präsident die
eigenen atomraketen in erhöhte
alarmbereitschaft versetzt hat und dann
was macht die nato gibt es da ein buch
das man raus zieht und das sagt man da
wenn das passiert dann machen wir das
nicht nicht wirklich natürlich wird
beraten auf politischer ebene de facto
ist es ja so wir haben ja eine große
kustodie alt macht das sind also die
wächter
zusagen der im klaren sprengköpfe das
sind die usa dort passiert nichts
solange der us präsident die nicht
freigibt so von daher spielt es
eigentlich keine rolle woher waffen in
europa stationiert sind ohne die
freigabe passiert nichts dann müsste sie
der nato-oberbefehlshaber sozusagen
autorisieren also wir haben eine lange
kette und dann ist aber auch die frage
braucht man eben wert von taktischen
waffen also wenn kleinere sachen die
irgendwo als demonstration eingesetzt
werden oder geht es gleich um das ganze
also hier ist ein ganz großes portfolio
dar darüber hinaus gibt es dann
natürlich noch die nuklearmächte england
und frankreich die wir nicht vergessen
sollten die aber aufgrund ihrer
kleinheit im grunde immer nur damit
drohen konnten moskau und andere
bevölkerungszentren auszurotten das wäre
sozusagen auch ein allerletztes mittel
mit dem man vorgehen könnte will sagen
hier gibt es hier gibt es alle guten
gründe zur zurückhaltung und auch gar
keine sorge dass wir irgendwelche fehler
könnten passieren können das ganze ist
so im detail durchdekliniert es gibt
auch nicht wie im kriegsfilm diese wie
soll ich mal sagen diese diese
möglichkeit da hat sich hier
einzumischen und irgendwelche dinge zu
machen das sind überall menschen
ja wie soll ich mal am werk die
technische prozeduren durchlaufen müssen
und auch reduzieren müssen dass etwaige
einsatz richtig sind also hier besteht
kein grund zur sorge im augenblick außer
der dass uns gut versichert und wir
sollten anfangen gibt zu glauben wenn er
uns droht dass er wenn wir uns
einmischen und auch immer
erklären lassen was soll man machen nach
den vergangenen tagen dann nimmt man die
drohungen natürlich ernst der camina das
ist eine meldung der ein total
erschaudern lässt das jetzt auch noch
die atomraketen in alarmbereitschaft
versetzt werden oder was macht das mit
ihnen
aber ich möchte zuerst nicht nur laden
recht geben ich glaube auch dass putin
im falsch beraten wurde von seinen
generälen
bekam er immer wieder die infos dass er
über die stärkste der welt verfügt von
seinen propaganda offizieren bekam er
die nachricht und das ukrainische
bevölkerung dieser russische armee
willkommen heißen wir tun beides kann
sich jetzt nicht bestätigt er erleidet
eine niederlage in der ukraine
ich glaube dass die atomwaffen und oder
die in bereitschaft gestellt werden ein
erpressungs mittel
gegen die regierung in der ukraine sind
putin kann diese mit dieser niederlage
kann er nicht nach hause
das gefährdet sein regime das würde das
ende des regimes bedeuten also muss er
einen sieg egal was es kostet erzwingen
also erpresste die ukraine mit nuklearen
sprengköpfen
also würden sie sagen ja camina das ist
sogar aktuell ein zeichen der schwäche
von putin dass er diesen schritt nur
auch noch geht weil die bilder die seit
vier tagen mittlerweile um die welt
gehen aus der ukraine
die lassen bisher nicht schließen auf
eine niederlage putins
na ja das sollte er sollte einen
blitzkrieg seien die großen städte
sollten schon längst besetzt sein und
die regierung ausgetauscht oder
mindestens dieser in gang also diese
prozessen garten gesetzt sie hatten dass
sie da sind immer die ersten zwei drei
tage entscheidend dass was passiert auch
der verzweifelte aufrufe an die
generalität
ukraine dass sie sollen
die macht übernehmen ist eigentlich
überhaupt nicht seine art er ist ja
immer derjenige gewesen der gegen jeden
punkt gegen jede machtübergabe
sich stellte
ist das so er die feuerwehr die das sind
hessen aus einer filiale mit allen
militärischen informationen die sie
aktuell auf den tisch bekommen die wir
auch hier vermelden dass sie den
eindruck haben ja das könnte im moment
gar nicht so gut stehen für putin und
für die russische armee der wollte das
ganz schnell schnell und jetzt geht's
halt nicht schnell schnell jetzt gewinnt
möglicherweise sogar die ukrainische
armee wieder nach und nach etwas die
oberhand
ich würde eine rakete in richtung grad
wäre das letzte mittel um diesen sieg zu
erzwingen
ich glaube dass das präsident sie lernen
es gibt niemals auch auf diese drohung
zugeht reagieren wird in dieser
situation muss europäische union glaube
ich eine einer
aktiv werden ich glaube nicht dass
atomraketen richtung russland
die richtige die richtige antwort werden
herr thiele noch mal die frage an sehen
ist das könnte das ein zeichen von
schwäche seien im moment auf russischer
seite auf putin seite dass er auch damit
jetzt noch droht ich halte das für
voreilig den anschluss putin hat de
facto einen siegeslauf wenn wir von
georgien durchschauen bei seinen
militärischen interventionen er kann
daher seine kräfte noch dramatische
skalieren unterhalb der gute anstellen
und von daher sollte man abwarten was
das jetzt im detail bedeutet natürlich
ist das jetzt kein überzeugender
überraschungsangriff das ist ja ganz
klar aber dennoch hat er viele
möglichkeiten zu eskalieren auf der
konventionellen seite und wir sollten
hier nicht in eine voreilige
siegeszuversicht kommen es ist für uns
glaube ich ein
100 unity also ein fenster eine
gelegenheits fenster vielleicht jetzt
doch in eine verhandlung mit ihnen
treten zu können bin da aber sehr
skeptisch da er auch als versierter
informations grüne krieger mit
lügenpropaganda exzellent umgehen kann
das ist ein schwieriges spiel aber wir
sollten die gelegenheit für die
ukrainische menschen nutzen dass das
morden den morgen einen einhalt zu
gebieten diese kleine hoffnungs meldung
kommt ja heute auch auf den tisch neben
diesen schauderhaften meldungen herr
meyer dass es offenbar einen
verhandlungstermin da gesucht wird
gerade wieder zwischen der russischen
und der ukrainischen seite jetzt setzt
man sich mit dem man wieder an den tisch
oder mit seinen leuten der seit vier
tagen die ukraine
bekämpft bekriegt und verhandelt über
über über was eigentlich dann ja ich
glaube das eigentlich das andere nicht
aus es ist durchaus ein pflänzchen
hoffnung dass es offenbar jetzt
bemühungen gibt an der
ukrainisch-russischen grenze
verhandlungen zu beginnen zwischen der
ukraine und russland
aber nichtsdestotrotz und das ist das
andere muss natürlich nach wie vor die
antwort hart bleiben auf putin auf dass
putin regime in moskau was
handelssanktionen anbelangt was
wirtschaftliche sanktionen anbelangt und
deswegen halte ich es auch für
vollkommen richtig dass jetzt auch die
nato streitkräfte ihre truppen
verstärken an der ostflanke um auch
deutlich zu machen wenn putin sich nur
im entferntesten wagen würde ein nato
mitgliedsland anzugreifen und ich finde
es auch richtig dass wir durchaus auch
dies erweitern auf die republik moldau
oder auch auf georgien dann greift er
alle an sprich er muss auch mit der
reaktion aller darauf rechnen und das
denke ich ist gestern auch die die
notwendige schärfe die hier auch
entgegengebracht werden muss es muss
deutlich gemacht werden es ist jetzt
schluss putin muss diesen krieg beenden
die frage ist ob er sich jetzt durch
diese sanktionen abschrecken lässt das
wird man sehen aber eines ist klar die
jetzt beschlossenen sanktionen werden
russland werden die wirtschaft russlands
in ganz enormer weise schwächen und
treffen und die hoffnung ist natürlich
auch dass es dann zumindest man auch in
der generalität und auch in der führungs
und orange um putin auch zu einem
umdenken kommt inwiefern diese entourage
einfluss hat auf putin das ist glaube
ich die große blackbox die momentan
keiner beantworten kann aber im moment
es ist ja schon auch so dass wir auch
zwangsläufig ganz viel erdgas abnehmen
aus russland herr müller das heißt wir
finanzieren aktuell und auf lange sicht
heraus diese kriegsmaschinerie von putin
mit lange sich das wird man sehen wir
haben auch das ja heute im bundestag
diskutiert dass wir uns schritt für
schritt und zwar jetzt sehr schnell und
verstärkt unabhängig machen und die
sache wochen um ihn herum deswegen muss
aber irgendwann damit anfangen um dieser
spirale raus zugelegt und deswegen ist
es richtig dass diese verständigung gibt
im übrigen ja auch zwischen vielen
europäisch zu tragen die sagen da wollen
wir nicht mehr dass wir aktuell
natürlich die kriegsmaschinerie ganz
wesentlich mit finanzieren das sind ja
keine genommen die wir dann nach moskau
aber andere das geld mir auch wieder
andere sanktionen die jetzt umgesetzt
werden die russland durchaus
wirtschaftlich auch schwächen werden und
sie haben nach den gesprächen gefragt
ich will dass an der stelle noch mal
betonen nach allem was wir wissen sagt
der ukrainische präsident er geht nicht
bedingungslos und solche gespräche
sondern er formuliert anforderungen das
ist richtig denn putin lügt und betrügt
das muss man wissen wenn man in solche
gespräche geht und muss anforderungen
formulieren aber weiter reden muss das
war in jeder phase die grundlage sein
wenn man aus dieser eskalation steven
wir gleich mit ukraine botschafter der
gleich auch hier dazu kommen wird in
unseren tag andrej melik trotzdem noch
mal bei der frage herr meier das ist ja
eine tiefe auch nicht nur moralische
frage sondern ganz pragmatisch der
geldhahn ist halt nicht abgedreht so
lange wir das er hat gas bezahlen
solange wir erdgas in so riesigen mengen
aus russland beziehen wie finanzieren
die kriegsmaschine von wladimir putin
wir müssen da aber auch natürlich
ehrlich miteinander umgehen wir beziehen
55 prozent des in deutschland
verbrauchten gases aus russland 40
prozent des öls das kann man nicht von
heute auf morgen verändern man kann
nicht von heute auf morgen den schalter
umlegen ich halte es für richtig dass
wir sehr intensiv bemühen alternativen
importeure zu finden sei es katar sei es
aber so was geht nicht von heute auf
morgen nur ehrlich sein wir tun so im
moment als würden wir knallhart mit
russland umgehen was einige bereiche
sicherlich auch tatsächlich zutrifft nur
herr kaminer wir schließen da wir
beenden das finale der champions league
das darf nicht mehr in sankt petersburg
stattfinden also beim fußball sind wir
dann jetzt langsam knallhart und gazprom
steht mich mehr auf dem schalke-trikot
aber wir finanzieren halt trotzdem über
das erdgas noch kräftig die
kriegsmaschine von putin besonders die
fußball entscheidung ich glaube mehrere
länder werden jetzt nicht mehr gegen
russland spielen
wollen dann stehen irgendwann mal auch
bei der fußball-wm russ und gegen
chinesen der finale
da hoffen wir dass wir das noch erleben
der camina jetzt ist gerade der
ukrainische botschafter hier
eingetroffen vielleicht fangen wir so
diese sendung an herzlich willkommen
andrej melik der camina vielleicht haben
sie auch der in unserer runde derjenige
ist der russische herkunft ein paar
worte an ihn zu richten an andere melnik
in diesen tagen empfinden sie sich
gemeinsam als brüder oder als
kriegsgegner
natürlich also natürlich als bruder und
ich möchte nämlich versichern dass alle
russen platz im ausland und im inland
die ein wenig bei verstand sind diesen
krieg verurteilen und nicht unterstützen
und in der ukrainischen almeria einen
einen sieg wünschen von ganzem herzen
hermeling befinden sie sich als brüder
oder aktuell das feld nämlich an die
angesichts der bilder natürlich der
vergangenen tage extrem schwer als
kriegsgegner also persönlich kennen wir
uns nicht aber
aber jeder deutsche kennt er inzwischen
herrn camina und für mich war wichtig
dass sie zu den wenigen menschen zu den
wenigen russen oder menschen mit
russischer herkunft gehören die für die
waffenlieferungen ganz öffentlich
aufgetreten haben und sie gesagt haben
ja dass das sollte geschehen und und
dafür bin ich ihnen persönliche aber vor
allem meine landsleute die gerade auch
versuchen die kirche zu verteidigen sehr
sehr dankbar jetzt waren wir gerade hier
in der runde herr melnik in der bei der
frage wie das eigentlich ist mit dem
finanzieren der kriegsmaschine putins ja
wir sind weiter schritte gegangen wir
haben swift jetzt nach langen
diskussionen
gecancelt mit den russen zumindest in
weiten teilen wir haben auch sonst die
sanktions spirale kräftig angezogen wir
haben auch heute im bundestag eine
kraftvolle rede von bundeskanzler olaf
scholz gehört mit ankündigung bei denen
man dann auch mal gucken muss wann die
umsetzbar sind und wann die früchte
tragen aber wir beziehen halt weiterhin
das russische erdgas und zahlen nach
moskau das ist eine gute frage wir sind
natürlich sind wir dankbar dafür dass
das die ampel regierung gestern und
vorgestern diese wichtigen
entscheidungen getroffen hatte in bezug
auf diese neuen sanktions pakete und
auch stifte gehört endlich dazu nur wir
haben angst dass das eben nur ein halber
schritt
wäre und dass dort auch schlupflöcher
geben könnte um eben dann doch die
kriegsmaschinerie putins finanzieren zu
können und deswegen glauben wir dass man
natürlich nicht nur diese banken die
sanktioniert sind jetzt ausschalten
sollte sollte auch das gesamte bahn
system russlands zu treffen und auch
dieses embargo embargo für importe aus
russland von wird das folgen haben bei
den hof bleiben also das ist noch einen
tick zu wenig man könnte noch anziehen
sagt hennig ich bin der meinung man muss
sich natürlich auch noch weitere
schritte offen halten es wäre vollkommen
deplatziert wenn man jetzt sagen würde
mit diesem sanktionspaket ist alles
erledigt wenn es hier vor allem auch
zielgerichtet effektiv weitere
möglichkeiten gibt die russische
wirtschaft das russische bankensystem
finanzierungssystem zutreffen dann
glaube ich sollte man sich diese option
natürlich offen halten glaubt so laufen
halt man fragt sich so ein bisschen was
wenn nicht jetzt eigentlich nach den
ereignissen der letzten vier tage sie
haben aber gerade schon den kopf
geschüttelt herr müller natürlich
brauchen wir energie nur wird das ist
der preis offenbar den die ukraine zahlt
dass wir sagen okay das ist es uns noch
nicht wert unserer energieversorgung
einzuschränken noch sind wir nicht so
weit noch haben wir nicht genügend tote
noch beziehen wir reden hier über zwei
verschiedene dinge die wir reden über
diesen aktuellen militärischen konflikt
und wir müssen alles tun um einerseits
die ukraine zu unterstützen und
andererseits das so schnell wie möglich
zu beenden das morden das sterben das
darf nicht mehr stattfinden aber das
findet das andere ja aber die nächsten
tage oder wochen glaube ich wird
unabhängig von den energielieferungen
russland genug mittel haben um diesen
krieg durchzusetzen den putin da will so
schlimm es ist wir reden also darüber
wie wir das so schnell wie möglich
beenden und wir müssen auf der anderen
seite darüber reden wie wir rauskommen
aus dieser spirale von russland abhängig
zu sein und das ist wichtig und richtig
dass wir uns auf andere beine stellen
das wir sehen dass wir andere
energieversorgungssysteme organisieren
mit anderen partnern arbeiten beides nur
stattfinden das eine wie das andere und
es hier vermischen ist im moment jetzt
für diese tage in denen wir uns hat in
brasilia es hat direkt mit dem
miteinander zu tun aber wenn wir sagen
ab morgen nehmen wir das nicht mehr das
erdgas oder erdöl wird leider so schlimm
ist es putin glaube ich genug
möglichkeiten haben um diesen krieg
gegen die ukraine zu führen und wir
müssen beides verändern also eher wenig
so ein boykott kommt aus den von den
müller genannten gründen aktuell ein
boykott von russischem erdgas nicht in
frage also wir glauben noch nicht gesagt
wenn man eine
ssl ihn aber herr mayer hat beim grillen
ich glaube das kann man
parteiübergreifend für viele sagen es
gibt eskalationsspirale und es gibt
möglichkeiten die gegebenenfalls auch
gezogen werden müssen
wir glauben dass wenn man sich schon
endlich entschlossen hatte so dezidierte
und entschlossen zu handeln dann glaube
ich dass das man schon heute in der lage
sein sollte auch einen todesstoß dieser
kriegsmaschinerie von von herrn putin zu
versetzen und deswegen jetzt ist die
zeit und es ist eine schwierige
entscheidung das können wir verstehen
aber wie gesagt dieses importer soll das
embargo importstopp für die rohstoffe
und nicht nur für die wahl selber
sondern auch für andere rohstoffe
metalle usw das wirte herrn putin und
sein und sein netzwerk wirklich sehr
harter camina bedeutet bei ihnen
vermutlich weiß nicht ob sie mit gas
heizen aber bei ganz vielen in berlin
würde die heizung dann ja kalt bleiben
also in meinem dorf in brandenburg
reisen die meisten menschen mit erdwärme
und mit sorgen energie und ich möchte
sagen wir sollen auch nicht so tun als
gäbe es kein alternativer diesem
russischem gas als wir dessen überhaupt
keine andere energiequellen auf dem
planeten geben das stimmt nicht da ja
das wird teurer
das wird nicht so günstig wie dieser
russische gas aber letzten endes glaube
ich werden wir dadurch mehr gewinnen als
verlieren
wenn wir uns von dieser abhängigkeit los
binden das ist natürlich schwierig im
kapitalismus so habe ich auch dieser
nord stream 2 schon immer als einer
strikt gesehen
wie heißt es doch so dass die
kapitalisten selbst dem streak
einem verkauf und an dem sie
aufkommen die sich selber erhängen
sollen dass wir so hat sich deutschland
und halb europas und fast dahinter an
diesem nord stream 2 dank des ehemaligen
bundeskanzlers unter anderem ist jetzt
sicher ändern ja herr ma ja nochmal zu
dieser schwierigen frage wir alle wissen
wie kompliziert das ist mit der
energieversorgung da müssen wir also
auch ehrlich machen nur wir müssen uns
auf der anderen seite hat auch ehrlich
machen dass das noch ja dazu beiträgt
dass die kriegsmaschine finanziert wird
also ist nicht ein boykott ein embargo
bisher nicht gerade nennt und herr
kaminer sagt er so kompliziert ist das
doch gar nicht wir werden schon
alternative energieträger finden also
ist dass sich der ehrliche schritt jetzt
aktuell boykott ein embargo ein ganz
klares prioritäres ziel muss es sein die
abhängigkeit von fossilen energieträgern
aus russland zu reduzieren iran aber
richtig ich sage nicht langfristig aber
es geht mit sicherheit nicht von heute
auf morgen das habe ich gesagt und es
geht leider auch nicht so wie es die
ampel regierung gesagt hat man ja wir
sind vielleicht gar nicht mehr so
abhängig von russischem gas weil es
kommt dann das frühjahr aber doch wir
brauchen
jetzt sehen wir ihn auch über 15 jahre
aber wir reden natürlich auch nicht über
ein 2 wochen wir brauchen ein neues
energiekonzept und wir müssen uns hier
auch ehrlich machen friedrich merz heute
sind heute in seiner rede finde ich auch
sehr beeindruckend und auch sehr richtig
festgestellt natürlich ist dieser
angriffskrieg dieser brutale
verwerfliche angriffskrieg russlands von
putin auf die ukraine eine zäsur in
vielerlei hinsicht was die
sicherheitsarchitektur was die
verteidigungsarchitektur deutschlands
anbelangt wir müssen entsprechende
rückschlüsse ziehen was die bessere
ausstattung unserer bundeswehr anbelangt
aber wir müssen auch rückschlüsse ziehen
was unser energiekonzept nun sind wir
genau da setzt der bundeskanzler hat
heute deutlich gemacht wir bauen jetzt
zwei neue terminal für flüssiggas in
deutschland hier sollen neue
partnerschaften
sie haben eine frage der zeit wie lange
das braucht ist ja eine ganz
entscheidende frage ob es dann nämlich
noch die ukraine gibt oder nicht herr
meyer also kommt die unabhängigkeit von
russischen gas noch bevor herr melnik
sein staat möglicherweise los ist also
bei dem bei dem punkt bin ich wirklich
bei herrn müller ich bin auch der
auffassung dass putin und seine schergen
genügend mittel haben um diesen
verwerflichen um diesen brutalen
angriffs krieg auch in den nächsten
tagen und wochen weiter fortzusetzen
unabhängig davon ob die wiesn aus
deutschland oder aus anderen ländern
nach moskau oder nach sankt petersburg
fließen aber natürlich brauchen wir neue
konzepte und ich war ja heute auch bass
erstaunt dass der bundeskanzler in
vielerlei hinsicht ja positionen
revidiert hat die noch vor zehn
zwanzig tagen 180 tagen waren in der
arena besaß die zwei prozent was das 2
prozent kriterium anbelangt was die
bessere ausstattung der bundeswehr
anbelangt es gab ein klares ziel der
ampel regierung die
verteidigungsausgaben um zehn prozent zu
kürzen ich bin froh und die sagt jan
müller hier auch ganz deutlich zu er hat
ja auch die unterstützung der csu wenn
es darum geht diese konzepte oder diese
ankündigungen die heute gemacht wurden
vom tesla auch entsprechend umzusetzen
über diese 180 grad wende die da heute
passiert ist sprechen wir gleich näher
vor allen dingen mit ihnen keines
botschafter andrej melik sind gleich
zurück nachher ganz kurzen pause
zurück bei bild die richtigen fragen
ihrem studium mit ukraine botschafter
andrej melik mit michael müller berlins
langjähriger regierenden bürgermeister
und mit stephan mayer der neue csu
general wird und er ist herzlich
willkommen zurück wir streiten über ein
ja ganz besonders historischen tag ein
tag an dem russlands präsident putin nun
auch ganz offen mit seinen atomraketen
droht und ein tag an dem hunderttausende
berliner auf die straße gehen als
zeichen der solidarität für die ukraine
ein tag in dem im bundestag scholz der
kanzler eine regierungserklärung gibt
und gleichzeitig auf der tribüne oben
andrej melik ukraine botschafter sitzt
und steht und standing ovations bekommt
im deutschen bundestag herr wenig wenn
ich mich recht entsinne hat sich da die
stimmung auch ihnen gegenüber ganz
erheblich verändert in den vergangenen
tagen sie sind verlacht worden sie waren
fast persona non grata in berlin das
kann man glaube ich so sagen
regierungsmitglieder haben uns gesagt
mit dem man kann man eigentlich nicht
mehr sprechen und jetzt bekommen sie
standing ovations heute im bundestag
also dieses standing ovations gelten vor
allem der ukraine und meinem volke und
auch unsere armee sie wurden alle
unterschätzte nicht nur von den russen
sondern vor allem oder auch von von
unseren westlichen freunde und partner
das war bitter vor allem am ersten tage
als der krieg ausbrach das war ja am
donnerstag und heute sehen wir dass die
ukraine immer noch da ist dass es noch
keinen
regierungswechsel gab der kein
vichy-regime putin natürlich einsetzen
wollte angebliche sondern keine
großstadt ist gefallen ganz im gegenteil
die ukraine sind entschlossene wie nie
zuvor weiterhin zu kämpfen für ihre
heimat und deswegen das war natürlich
ein sehr bewegender moment für mich da
zu sein das war einmalig in der
geschichte dass der bundestag dieser
sondersitzung an einem sonntag hält und
deswegen war das auch ein wichtiges
signal nach kiew als signal der stärke
der unterstützung für mein land sollte
dass sie weiterhin nicht alleine sind
sie haben selbst der harte worte die im
vorfeld sind dafür extrem scharf aber
auch kritisiert worden auch aus der
ampel regierung auch von aktiven
regierungsmitgliedern sie haben
vergangene woche noch hier ende
vergangener woche hierbei bild gesagt
dass es regierungsmitglieder gebe die
sagen ihr haltet nicht mehr lange durch
die ukraine wird es nicht mehr lange
geben und dann das heute diese
emotionalen bilder dort was ist in
dieser zeit plötzlich passiert hat man
jetzt in der deutschen regierung
verstanden
diese vier lange tage des krieges
erscheinen wie eine ewigkeit für mich zu
sein und ja das war bitter in der tat am
anfang am donnerstag als als wir gehört
haben dass das ja uns kaum eine chance
einräumen dass die ukraine bald fallen
wir dass wir fast erledigt geliefert
sind und das war dann nicht nur
politiker die das nahe gelegt oder auch
gegen direkt gesagt haben auch viele
militärexperte keine chance wie die
ukraine und jetzt wo wir sehen die
ukrainische armee ist der stärker als je
zuvor und die menschen der kampfgeist
ist ungebrochen glauben sie mir also
alle meine freunde nicht nur der
präsident der den menschen mut machte er
bleibt in kiew wollte nicht evakuiert
werden wie vorgeschlagen meine familie
ist in kiew meine schwiegermutter sind
in kiew meine nichte hat wieder schon
die dritte nacht verbracht im keller und
kann ich verstehen oder jetzt verstellt
sich schon was ein krieg bedeutete und
wir hoffen dass auch hier die deutschen
das begriffen haben es lohnt sich uns zu
unterstützen es ist zu späte uns
aufzugeben ich finde an diesen bildern
herr müller kann man so sehr zeigen wie
groß diese wende eben aktuell in der
bundesregierung ist in der koalition
aktuell wenn sie das sehen wie man mit
herrn malick auch in den vergangenen
tagen umgegangen ist und heute gibt es
diesen applaus dieses standing ovations
im bundestag wie glaubwürdig ist dann
eine solche wende auch also eher wenig
ist ja ein freund klarer worte und es
mal vorsichtig zu sagen auch in den
vorwürfen der bundesregierung gegenüber
und das wurde dann auch mal deutlich
zurückgewiesen und das hätte auch aus
will und dass wir uns schwer tun mit
rüst und mit waffenlieferungen mit
militärischen konflikten das kann man
doch vielleicht auch nachvollziehen
gerade wenn man die geschichte unseres
landes kennt aber dass sich auch meinung
verändert auch wenn die situation sich
verändert wenn wir sehen was in der
ukraine passiert und last hinter ihn und
nahm sehr klatsch klatsch die ganze spd
fraktion ist das bei allen in ihrer
fraktion er mir kommt bei allen ja es
ist bei allen angekommen helfen man
nicht so sagen herr will das kann ich so
sagen ja es ist ja deutlich geworden sie
sagen ja gerade die ganze spd fraktion
klatscht ja mit gottes segen ja aber das
was da jetzt passiert waren ja nicht nur
schöne wort auch die sind wichtig herr
melnik sagt auch diese solidarität heute
seinem volk gegenüber war ein wichtiges
zeichen aber es ist ja dabei nicht
geblieben sondern unterstützt von der
spd fraktion vom fraktionsvorsitzenden
hat der bundeskanzler deutlich gemacht
was passiert an waffenlieferung an
sanktionen an und hängen unabhängig
machen von von russland und das muss man
sehen das ist natürlich eine veränderung
jetzt eine veränderte haltung aber eben
auch weil man darauf reagieren muss was
da passiert in der ukraine und deswegen
ist es doch richtig wenn dann eine
regierung auch sagt wir sehen das und
wir passen unsere politik entsprechend
an ich weiß schon herr meyer dass sie es
parteipolitisch auch parteipolitisch
machen wollen sehe ich jetzt glaube ich
glaube ich an ihren blick das tierleid
lassen uns bei herrn mail nicht bleiben
das interessiert mich was er konkret von
dem was herr scholz heute was die ampel
heute was die aussenministerin was der
vizekanzler was der finanzminister heute
bundestag gesagt habe was ihr
fraktionschef heute im bundestag gesagt
was konkret kommt innerhalb kurzer zeit
bei hennig an das sind nicht die 100
milliarden das werden vermutlich auch
nicht die waffen seien vermutlich also
wovon hat hermine ganz schnell etwas in
dieser verzweifelten kriegs lage in der
ukraine
also ich glaube schon dass die
botschaften die heute von der
regierungserklärung aber auch von der
alten debatte ausgegangen sind wichtige
signale setzen und nicht nur signale
sondern auch tatsächliche unterstützung
darstellen für die ukraine für das
ukrainische volk die waffenlieferungen
sind richtig die panzerabwehrraketen die
die boden luft raketen sind richtig und
sie werden auch etwas bewirken da bin
ich mir auch sehr sicher werden die da
sein was glauben sie ich hoffe ich
schneller als die die hell 15 5000 her
denn so lange dauert 5000 helme darüber
zuschauer abholen so weil ich das mit
abwehr
regelrecht das war mit verlaub keine
glanzleistung ihre arbeit jetzt mach ich
es wirklich so ist es ist nicht witzig
deswegen mache ich mir auch nicht so
leicht mich hier nur auf opposition auf
die oppositionsrolle zu beziehen ich
habe vorher gesagt die die regierung
herr müller hat unsere unterstützung
wenn es darum geht entsprechend jetzt
diese veränderungen in der
sicherheitsarchitektur in der
verteidigung verteidigungshaushalt auch
im energiekonzept entsprechend auch ins
werk zu setzen wir sind eine
konstruktive opposition wir könnten es
uns auch leichter machen aber ich glaube
gerade in dieser schwierigen humanitären
krise in der ukraine steckt aber die
natürlich auch unmittelbare auswirkungen
auf deutschland heute und ich bekomme
ich ja auch im persönlichen umfeld mit
so viele menschen haben angst dass der
krieg natürlich auch nach deutschland
kommt in dieser krisenhaften situation
bedarf es auch eines schulterschlusses
zwischen demokraten auch über regierungs
und oppositionskreisen hinweg deswegen
mache ich mir nicht so leicht für mich
nur auf die oppositionsrolle celik noch
einmal zu der frage der waffen zurück
die jetzt angekündigt die versprochen
sind dann müssten die denn da sein damit
es noch hilft weil wir wissen dass die
lage in kiew ja in der hauptstadt in
weiten teilen des landes dramatisch ist
also die werden doch jetzt gebraucht die
waffen dann müssten die da sein ich habe
mich gestern mit verteidigungsminister
in programmbericht getroffen bevor die
entscheidung dann verkündete wurde und
danach habe ich mich auch telefonisch
bedankt und meine frage war auch aber
vor allem die frage ob ski wenn ich habe
sofort meine präsidentin informierten
außenminister waren sind sie da war die
frage aus kirche und die gleiche frage
habe ich habe die ministerin berichtete
sie hat mir versprochen dass da sofort
geschieht also vielleicht noch gestern
gestern war das nicht mehr möglich
wahrscheinlich aus technischen gründen
aber vielleicht heute könnte das soweit
sein dass die waffen auf den weg
geschickt werden über den landweg und
hauptsache dass sie so schnell wie
möglich da ankommen wo sie benötigt
werden und sie werden benötigt von der
verteidiger von care von anderen
großstädten die jetzt seit zwei tagen
massiv massivs in der nacht bombardiert
wurden und dass immer mehr zivilisten zu
tode kommen das muss man schnell das
verhindert sprechen wir darüber mit ober
study
der uns zugeschaltet ist ralf thiele wie
kriegt man jetzt diese menge an
panzerfäusten an
flugabwehrraketen nach kiew das ist ja
nicht leicht der luftraum ist gesperrt
das russische sind russische truppen im
land man kommt teilweise ganz schwer
überhaupt in die stadt rein nach kiew da
sind brücken zerstört bahnstrecken
zerstört und so weiter wie bekommt man
diese waffen jetzt ins land und vor
allen dingen auch in die hauptstadt gute
frage nächste frage
putin saß weiß viel wir sollten ihnen
tatsächlich nicht alles sagen denn wir
wünschen uns doch dass diese waffen von
den ukrainern zur verteidigung genutzt
werden kann stehe aber erhalten sie das
überhaupt für realistisch also sind die
wege noch so offen geht das dann immer
irgendwie in dem krieg die stimme ist
einfach wahnsinnig schwierig vor es geht
um einen übergabepunkt aber wie gesagt
wir bewegen uns auf einem schlechten tag
an dem man festlegen muss und wo man
sich dann trifft und sie können sicher
sein dass zum beispiel auch moderne
operationsmethoden
handy cyber genutzt werden um das genau
zu verfolgen also nochmal ist weniger
wir darüber sprechen wir besser ist es
für geben kann die helme wurden in polen
übergeben wenn ich richtig informiert
bin hermeling das war schon kompliziert
die 5000 filme zu übergeben jetzt
schließt sich möglicherweise dieses
zeitfenster ist es auch nicht gerade top
of the pops was wir da an waffen liefern
können sie damit überhaupt was anfangen
gegen die hochgerüstete ja auch nicht
immer in bestem zustand agieren dann
aber doch hochgerüstete russische armee
also alte flugabwehrraketen und
panzerfäuste also man darf das nicht
unterschätzen also auch diese diesen
ersten schritt der hilfe und deswegen
wenn wenn die waffen ankommen dann
können sie tatsächlich die lage
verändern und sie können tatsächlich vor
allem diese dinge
luft systeme sind die sind sehr
wirkungsvoll und sie können schon helfen
also diese lufthoheit der russen die sie
in den ersten zwei drei tagen errungen
haben auch in der nähe von kiel könnte
man zum erliegen bringen denn es waren
noch helikopter ja es war der ziele die
mit solchen städten durchaus vernichtet
werden können auch wenn man wenn man
nicht geübt ist denn es ist schon da
sind keine sind schulter gestützten
waffensysteme und wir hoffen schon dass
sie einen unterschied machen aber das
war nur ein erster schritt das darüber
haben wir gesprochen mit der
bundesregierung dass wir natürlich weil
dieser krieg noch sich hinter länge
ziehen kann es ist nicht so interessant
dass beide noch mal die eu steht hier ja
auch zusammen sie sagen zurecht was tut
die bundesregierung wir reden darüber
aber auch die anderen europäischen
staaten unterstützen ja und das greift
vielleicht ja vielleicht nein das ist
eben auch eine neue qualität dass die eu
sich nicht auseinanderdividieren lässt
sondern dass die hilfe ineinander greift
für die ukraine ist eine neue qualität
und ich glaube das hat putin gar nicht
bedacht wie er hier auch die eu und die
nato zusammen schweißen putin hat genau
recht gehabt dass deutschland sie
wahnsinnig schwer tut und wahnsinnig
viele tage braucht um eben dann auch zu
dem schluss andere eu-staaten zu kommen
es hat sehr lange gedauert 44 lange
harte kriegstage die hand melnik wie
eine ewigkeit vorkommen aber das ist
interessant was ja gerade sagt hermeling
herr meyer dass weitere
waffenlieferungen folgen können das ist
jetzt nicht finale sozusagen ein mal
rüber schicken da könnte mehr folgen das
ist ein einstieg aus sicht der csu auf
jeden fall ich habe vorher gesagt es
darf nichts ausgeschlossen werden was
sanktionen anbelangt auch hier müssen
wir uns auf jeden fall die möglichkeit
offen halten dass wir weiter eskalieren
dass wir weitere stufen entsprechend
auch noch in wirkung bringen und
gleiches gilt aus meiner sicht auch für
waffenlieferungen
ich hielte es für falsch wenn wir jetzt
hier apodiktisch sorgen mit diesen 500
panzerabwehrraketen und 1000
boden-luft-raketen war es also ist ich
bin sogar der meinung wir sollten offen
sein für weitere waffenlieferungen in
die ukraine der camina sie zurück ins
gespräch holen toll dass sie heute bei
uns sind und
uns ja ein bisschen aus ihrer deutsch
russischen seele darauf blicken lassen
auf diese debatte die jetzt ja auch hier
in deutschland entbrennt also wir haben
uns immer
ja ist relativ leicht gemacht indem wir
gesagt haben aus historischen gründen
können wir eben keine waffen liefern das
gilt jetzt plötzlich nicht mehr oder
halten sie das was jetzt heute passiert
ist in diesem ersten schritt auch mehr
oder weniger für eine symbolpolitik
heute früh um mir mein freund aus faro
erzählt dass vor seinem chaos auf der
siegessäule russische bahn verstehen das
letzte mal
waren sie dort vor 80 jahren als sie die
panzer der faschisten haushalt
vertrieben haben hier sind sie selbst
die angreifer und und wollen das land
kopieren aber inzwischen sind diese
panzer dank deutschen raketen
wahrscheinlich aus der stadt vertrieben
worden zwei brennen und die anderen sind
weg
bleibt ukrainische staat das das ist
erstaunlich und ich reibe mir immer
wieder die augen dass die rollen in der
weltgeschichte sich so schnell verändern
können die deutschen befreien
ok von ukraine zu befreien vor einer
russischen kunden das heißt herr müller
das gilt ab heute nicht mehr dieses
diesen satz haben wir ab heute zum
letzten mal gehört dass wir nicht in
kriegsgebiete in konfliktgebiete waffen
liefern das ist nicht mehr so diese
historische entschuldigung gilt ab heute
hier haben für diesen fall eine neue
position formuliert die bundesregierung
hat das heute deutlich gemacht und ich
wehre mich ein stück weit dagegen wir
wollen doch krieg verhindern auf einmal
daraus eine blaupause für jeden konflikt
zu machen wir müssen doch immer wieder
wenn es um militär wenn es um krieg geht
wenn es umrüstung geht immer wieder
genau hingucken was nötig ist und hier
ist es so hier ist heuer also die bilder
lassen und dabei bleiben weil die haben
schon jetzt auch für alle zeiten wir
sind hier in einige hielten ein wir sind
hier in einer situation wo es ein
himmelschreiendes unrecht der ukraine
gegenüber gibt und in dieser situation
muss man so handeln wie die
bundesregierung ist jetzt tut punkt ich
will nur wissen ob diese entschuldigung
noch einmal vorgebracht das heißt schon
was man sagt kraus redet dass man nicht
es ist kein rausreden indem man es war
kein risiko ich habe hier schon im
reiter kommen wir nicht zusammen es geht
um krieg und frieden es geht um rüstung
es geht um menschenleben und ja auch vor
dem hintergrund unserer geschichte ist
es für uns schwer mit rüstung und
rüstungsmaterial einzugreifen das ist
keine beliebige entschuldigung sondern
es sind echte gründe warum man sich
schwer tut und dass dann vor diesem
hintergrund trotzdem eine
bundesregierung sagt hier ist es genau
richtig auch mit rüstung zu helfen das
ist eine veränderte haltung ich finde
die man achten sollte dieser satz herr
mayer csu generalsekretär wir liefern
keine waffen in konfliktgebiete in
kriegsgebiete gilt er ab heute nicht
mehr
ich bin auch der meinung man muss jeden
einzelfall gesondert betrachten und es
gibt sehr gute gründe dafür wäre schöner
gewesen wenn wir es früher entschieden
hätten dass wir jetzt dass deutschland
waffen in die ukraine liefert das ist
eine richtige entscheidung aber ich
glaube auch mit verlaub wir haben jetzt
seit andere probleme in anderen
herausforderungen als jetzt die debatte
zu eröffnen ob dies jetzt generalisiert
für alle konfliktregionen gilt ich
glaube da haben wir nach der hoffentlich
baldigen beendigung dieses schrecklichen
angriffskriegs noch genügend zeit die
jetzt geht es darum dass wir alle
energie und alle konzentration darauf
richten dass wir der ukraine helfen in
humanitärer hinsicht was wir heute noch
gar nicht gesprochen haben dass wir uns
natürlich auch darauf vorbereiten sehr
aktiv darauf vorbereiten gerade auch auf
kommunaler ebene
bürgerkriegsflüchtlinge aus der ukraine
zu beherbergen aufzunehmen die bei ihnen
schon angekommen war die sind noch nicht
angekommen aber ich weiß von den
landräten auch von den form vom
bayerischen innenminister dass es
intensive vorbereitungen gibt dass auch
die hallen schon wieder auch linien aber
weiter sehr ziehen ja wir sind für
200.000 flüchtlinge glaube ich jetzt
schon in polen angekommen also das sind
doch jetzt handfeste herausforderungen
denen sich regierungen auseinandersetzen
müssen deswegen auch wenig wenn die
frage spannend ist ob jetzt dieses ob
dies jetzt apodiktisch gilt dass waffen
nicht mehr in krisengebiete geliefert
werden mit diesen fragen glaube ich kann
man sich später auch noch beschäftigen
zurück deswegen nach kiew in die
umkämpfte hauptstadt uns zugeschaltet
weiterhin ralf thiele der lange bei der
nato war wenn sie die nachrichten die
aktuellen einkommen zu der militärischen
lage dort rund um die hauptstadt
zusammen kratzen was glauben sie
wielange kann die ukraine das aushalten
diesem druck etwas entgegenzusetzen zu
haben
ja ich bin wie alle seriösen experten
natürlich überrascht und beeindruckt von
den kampfwillen von dem
durchhaltevermögen von der motivation
sich muss ich leider sagen weil ich eben
weiß über welches enormes potenzial
russland verfügt das sind ja ähnlich die
panzer allein die wir immer anzeigen
sondern es ist ja sozusagen ein sehr
umfangreiches potenzial das von
satelliten über elektronische
kampfführung über zwei jahre zusammen
kalten über spezialkräfte ganz breit
gestreut ist und im grunde sehen wir
erst einen kleinen teil des russischen
potenzials in der ukraine trotzdem
unglaublich bemerkenswert und ich glaube
jeder tag zählt vielleicht doch noch in
eine verhandlungslösung hinein kommen zu
können das heißt es droht natürlich der
ukrainischen armee den soldaten all den
bürgern die dagegen wer gerade zeigen
erbittert ja dass die luft ausgeht nach
welcher zeit nach einigen tagen nach
einigen wochen deswegen habe ich das
auch erwähnt also wir sind dankbar und
erleichtert dass die bundesliga die
glauben sie dass sie solche komisch
erhalte jetzt aber wir jetzt brauchen
wir auch weiterhin nachschub und zwar
nicht nur was dieser defensiv war von
angeht da hoffe ich haben wir auch
verständnis in berlin sondern wir
brauchen auch das wasser berlin während
der blockade
wenn nötig hatte diese luftbrücke jetzt
müssen wir auch eine eine westbrücke
aufbauen denn wie gesagt die die
wirtschaft steht still im moment und
sagte vier tagen also kiew es ist still
keine läden also keine banken keine
geschäfte nicht auch viele fabriken
mussten schließen weil menschen sich hin
jetzt natürlich in sicherheit gebracht
werden mussten und deswegen man müsste
jetzt schon jetzt beginnen und nicht nur
für die flüchtlinge zu sorgen dafür sind
wir dankbar dass solche luftbrücke
liefern könnten diese auch lebensmittel
zum beispiel nach superkraftstoff das
geschieht zum teil schon jetzt und wir
sind dankbar dass es geht darum dass wir
eine eine eine ader eine lebensader
errichten schon heute aus deutschland
aus anderen europäischen staaten unserer
partner über polen über andere
grenzstaaten im westen der ukraine in
der miete der mieter das leben am am
laufen gehalten werden kann die
wirtschaft auf die beine kommt und nur
so könnten wir auch weiterhin
standhalten und diesen angriff abwehren
den tagen in denen wir erleben dass der
krieg zu unser aller alltag wird vor
allen dingen zu ihrem alltag herr
kaminer unsere hoffnung hier ich glaube
alle am tisch und zugeschaltet ist dass
sich innerhalb russlands irgendwie was
tut wir sehen dann proteste in vielen
städten ungefähr 50 städten das ist
natürlich eine eine winzige minderheit
dort in russland die dann auf die straße
geht dort zu sehen ist und trotzdem gibt
es diese hoffnung die natürlich vor
allen dingen von ihrer branche sozusagen
ausgeht von kulturschaffenden
von intellektuellen aber sehen sie
tatsächlich irgendeine chance dass sich
das über das land ausbreitete dass wir
da protest sehen in einer bevölkerung
die eigentlich gar keine waren
informationen über das pferd was dort im
land von hennig gerade vor sich geht
ja ich stelle die zukunft russlands
liegt heute in den ruinen von kiew es
gibt tatsächlich große hoffnung dass ein
verlorener krieg
der beginn vom ende dieses regimes
putins regime ssten sein kann
ein wagen erhalten die die bevölkerung
russische bevölkerung
ist natürlich
politisch sehr agil und kann ihre
führung sehr viel verzeihen aber
nicht einem verlorenen krieg und ich
glaube dass da das booten tatsächlich in
eine falle gelockt wurde aber diese
klick war auf eine niederlage
programmiert man man kann gar nicht 40
millionen großes land auf dauer
kopieren ich weiß nicht wer also ich
weiß es schon der ihm die erzählt hat
dass du kleine sich erfreuen würden und
die russischen soldaten mit blumen
begrüßen
das war das war bis jetzt sein größtes
außenpolitisches fehler und ich hoffe
sehr dass diese verlorene krieg
tatsächlich so eine änderung im
russische politik auch hüllt die
russische community hier in deutschland
nach ihrem eindruck herr kaminer ist die
aktuelle er stolz auf putin oder schämt
sie sich für ihn
das kommt darauf an welche
welche fernsehkanäle dieser community
schaut also machen als in licht und
meistens nicht ard zdf und meistens
leider leider auch nicht bild
ja also wenn sich wenn sie ruhe im
russischen fernsehen wird ja das wort
krieg gar nicht ausgesprochen meine
mutter schaut dem duell im russischen
fernsehen also sie weiß nichts von krieg
es geht um eine gleiche operation die
auch sehr bald zu hören sein wird und
auf dringende bitte des griechischen
volkes ein lied durchgeführt wird das
was die mehrheit denkt weiß ich nicht
ich kann es nicht sagen ich weiß nur
dass mein ukraine freunde selber rascht
waren wie viele russen zu ihren
protesten dazu stießen am brandenburger
tor vor der russischen botschaft um
gegen diesen krieg zu protestieren und
ihre solidarität mit der ukraine zu
zeigen wo waren sie früher haben die
ukrainisch und freunde immer gesagt weil
für sie ist dieser krieg
nicht erst vor seit letzte woche sondern
seit 2014 gange es sind immerhin 15.000
ukrainer ermordet worden an der an der
ostukrainischen front also für viele ist
das natürlich viel nähe für silo kleiner
als die russen
ich
möchte ich möchte dass den meisten ich
möchte denken dass die meisten meine
landsleute in deutschland natürlich
diese lage auch die wir also mit großer
besorgnis und
hoffnung auf einen auf eine bessere
wendung sehen und natürlich viel kleiner
sind sagt vladimir kaminer der
schriftsteller an einem tag an dem ja
vladimir putin russlands präsident
sozusagen mit den atomraketen fuchtelt
in russland an dem wir einen weiteren
schrecklichen kriegstag in der ukraine
erlebt haben unter dem wir zum ende
dieser sendung kommen hier michael
müller wir haben heute erstaunliche
worte im bundestag gehört von ihrem
bundeskanzler letzte frage das war auch
ein tag der ruhe im bundestag zeigen sie
auch reue mit ihrer partei der schröder
partei der anti waffenlieferung partei
bisher in einen bestimmten phasen unsere
unserer bundespolitik ist es richtig und
wichtig gewesen auch so zu handeln und
zu sagen wir schließen auch ja unter der
merkel-regierung wir schließen
waffenlieferungen in krisengebiete
kriegsgebiete aus das war richtig und
nachvollziehbar aber ich sage noch
einmal eine lage zu beobachten und dann
zu sagen wir müssen möglicherweise
unsere position auch verändern das
schmückt er eine bundesregierung als
dass man ihr vorwerfen kann das waren
die schlussworte hier keine reue in
diesen worten von michael müller dankte
andere melnik danke stefan maier bei uns
im studio danke wladimir kaminer fürs
mitmachen und ralf thiele der lange bei
der nato war oberst a d danke ihnen
[Musik]